[Music]
i'm leave barker in london the top
stories on al jazeera
we
we start with breaking news sri lanka's
disgraced former president has returned
to the country less than two months
after he fled during the nation's worst
economic crisis in memory
kotabaya rajapaksa was blamed for
pushing sri lanka to financial disaster
as protesters across the country rallied
against his rule
minell fernandez is in colombo for us
but now this seems like an incredibly
risky move potentially for the former
president
it does so but uh at the end of the day
it just seems that gotabe rajapaksa ran
out of options he did flee on that
military plane to the maldives uh went
on to singapore from there and then
ended up in thailand all the while
looking at his options of where he could
go
uh in terms of governments had to be
willing and able to facilitate
that stay of his but he did find a lot
of closed doors and that's why we saw a
few weeks ago srpp members that's his
party uh sitting down with president
vikramazer
to try and work out uh and get a
security guarantee that he would be
allowed to return and that the
government would ensure his security so
i did speak to the minister of public
security who confirmed his return he
said uh he has already moved into an
official government-provided bungalow
that is his entitlement as a former head
of state uh there will be security
obviously again his entitlement as a
former leader but obviously given um the
sort of level of threats and things like
that they would be assessed but he did
say it's very early stages yet
he might not uh be able at this stage to
say you know is he getting back to
politics or whatever he did say it's
very early stages but he did say he was
relaxed uh
at being able to return
but now fernando is in colombo many
thanks